[Music]
hello everyone Perry here in Park City
right now we are at the kiyose upper
suite and we are super lucky that we
have Kia is a sponsor because we get to
talk about super cool movies like relic
and I have the team behind the movie
right here you guys know I've seen it
and I loved it huge congratulations
House house Sundance treating you so far
how was the how was the energy in the
REA last night it's been amazing yeah it
was yeah it was surreal to actually play
it in front of a large audience after
working on it for you know a year and a
half but yeah we're all pretty stoked I
think it was you should be it's just
very exciting yeah first for Sundance
for anyone here boy okay not first
Sundance
did you give anybody anybody advice and
advice for like making the most out of
it and I was in a very bad mood
yesterday until I saw the movie and then
I suddenly got into the most brilliant
move mood because I just really enjoyed
it which is very rare to enjoy something
that you're in and it was so peaceful
and so brilliant that it completely
turned me around but I was behaving
extremely grumpily and badly it was very
charming she's kind of like a Hugh Grant
kind of charming collagens so she handle
it well but I did get a text from Emily
2:45 saying I'm sorry I was so
ungrateful and miserable all day
something something films beautiful we
are beautiful in it and national he's a
genius so that was which is how I
thought you were so charming yesterday
what do you say just complaining about
going around to all you know you
basically spend the whole day going from
like one room to another room that's
like two houses down and taking the same
photograph and not even talking about
the film and you're like and then at one
point we were made to sit in miniature
furniture which was as far as I could
see an advert for Chase Bank and I was
like what is this so but today is much
better because we're actually talking
about the phone yes so I think we've
gotten a little ahead of ourselves
because I do think that people are gonna
hear about relic very soon but we have a
lot of viewers out there who do not know
what the movie is about so I must give
the studio to you right now can you give
a brief synopsis of relic for our
viewers yeah absolutely
relic is quite a personal exploration of
Alzheimer's but told through a horror
haunts
house story so the setup is that the
it's about three woman so a grandmother
a mother and a daughter the grandmother
goes missing you know at the start of
the film so the mother and daughter have
to go back to search for her in her you
know very remote country house and but
she comes back very soon after but she's
come back changed so it's about having
to the mother and daughter having to
figure out whether it's the Alzheimer's
or whether it's something supernatural
so can you tell us a little bit about
the proof of concept short and just how
that helped you get this full feature
off the grounds yeah absolutely we
actually had a first draft of relic when
we made our proof of concept so it was a
very conscious decision to make a much
more succinct version of the story
characters were different but the tone
setting and themes were exactly the same
and we were lucky enough that it played
it quite a few drama festivals and yeah
that actually got me signed with WME and
then from there I'd already had my
Australian producers cover films but
then we managed to find some an us
partner producing partner and then
eventually AG both films came on board
as an investor's Jake Gyllenhaal oh yes
nice stories yes as well as I was
reading Hailey's article thank you I did
my homework yes a very good team to have
at your back here and then you assemble
an incredible trio of leading ladies
right here
I was curious though is there any
particular role that you felt you needed
to cast first and then build around that
character or did it all just come
together naturally I think there were
quite a few conversations and
brainstorming sessions obviously it's a
it's a challenge when you they have to
you know feasibly be mother and daughter
as well I think particularly I think
Edna's role just because of the age
range and the amount of actors who are
you know at a certain caliber and
working you know at that age I think
yeah I think we we certainly considered
ed no first for practical reasons and
yeah just yeah and and Robin was always
top of the list for me so yeah
who here is a big horror fan okay you're
not allowed to say no you're in scream
three and everybody here knows how I
feel about that franchise including that
installment and then I guess I just got
wimpy as I got older but like I remember
watching scream take away our joy no I
loved I loved that I loved making that
film Wes Craven is just was just such a
gentleman and such a brilliant peaceful
person and I hit the best I mean I
couldn't believe I just arrived in LA to
be with my boyfriend who's now my
husband and I got that job and I
suddenly found myself as being chased
and corridors in like 1930's mansions by
a person in a mask and just laughing and
crying laughing after each tale I just
think it's that should be therapy they
should organize that some therapy get
chased by a man in a scream once with a
dagger but yeah that was a very
different experience from this this was
much sort of I mean it was a real sort
of psychological I don't know it was it
was a bit psychologically very sort of
intense and and and difficult it wasn't
like her kind of campy horror film in
any way no I I find it a fascinating and
extremely effective when you use horror
as a tool to dig into certain very you
know touchy and difficult topics because
it usually brings out you know nuances
and can maybe help someone understand a
situation more so than they would have
if it were a straightforward film but
this this is a lot for you guys so what
is step one after you get the roles is
it a table read is it just a casual
conversation between the three of you to
kind of build that family history we
yeah we had a table read
were you there oh god I can't remember
yeah yes yeah we had a few days with
Natalie and chatting more than anything
because becoming familiar I suppose with
each other and it was the opportunity to
ask questions about backstories and
whatever we needed felt we needed to
know but I was just gonna say you also
in preparation I remember we well I
didn't we talked about Alzheimer's a lot
and you visited the nursing home yes I
may be not so helpful
I remember we hated a lot of kind of
material yes not it didn't actually
really help because I remember saying to
Natalie well because what I needed to do
was just do whatever the Swift told me
completely moment-by-moment yeah and
that's how you achieve the you know the
the entire arc of the stories just
moment by moment yeah so it research
actually didn't help me at all yes a
research she's probably yeah more for
the writing and it helps to inform you
know the script but yeah for these guys
like Bella and Emily I definitely we
didn't talk about you know the kind of
specifics of Alzheimer's at all it was
yeah I think I definitely just draw on
personal experience and conversations we
had and more - spending time together I
just remember the fur but when Emily
there was all this anxiety about like
and we had this incredible incredible
series of events that like canceled
flights and like Emily God was like
she's later and later later and will she
be there on the first day and like all
this anxiety and then she turned up and
she was just like this delightful hot
mess and I just immediately I was like
okay great you're my mum my best friend
for life no but but I just it was just I
feel like we just naturally fell into
some sort of family dynamic maybe
because I think we just really like all
liked each other well I liked you guys I
really felt like what I just was
immediately struck on that first day of
sitting around that table together that
had assembled just some really cool like
just not I'm not usual people like
really cool women that just reminded me
of people I loved but I don't know
sometimes just straight and not no
pretension and just down-to-earth kind
of cool funny ladies and it was just so
it was such a treat thank God for that
because it was very trying the filming
process it was really hard and um it was
just it was it was totally mitigated by
the fact that we were together rather
than some annoying people that could
have been but I also think it's
something is something about the set to
it's a feeling on the set it's an
atmosphere on the on the set that's set
by the person at the top and if that's
not focused and and and kind of quiet
know what I mean quiet
I mean focused I suppose really gentle
yes and calm Natalie was very calm god
knows what she was like inside but she
was calm and clear very incisive she
knew exactly what she wanted she was
demanding and and and I trusted and
respected her so from that perspective
it was kind of not easy but it it just
sort of the follow-through was there
because the script was clear she was
cleared they were great so it was good
can you tell me a little bit about your
process as an actor's director unset and
just what your note giving process is
whether really because like the props
and all the set decorate like there's so
many very specific details that in my
mind I would assume you'd have to map it
all out right okay so do you mean the
the set or the actors a little of a
little of everything is the plot seems
very specific the same it's just the
world that you build feels very lived in
and in my mind I just automatically make
the assumptions you guys got to play in
the house yeah yeah free-flowing vibe we
definitely didn't you know we'd never
never actually got up and rehearsed
scenes it was more about I think with
the actors just talking about life and
sharing stories and experiences and
finding common ground I think that's
always the most important thing to -
yeah have a mutual understanding of
what the character is going through and
then yeah and then I prefer to I prefer
to you know feel it out on onset and
obviously when you're working with
actors of such a caliber it doesn't you
don't need a lot of prior prep time to
ease into that it's not like working
with known actors or kids or anything
like that so yeah I would say I don't
know it's it's hard to define your own
process but yeah apparently a lot of
notes I think probably my favorite Robin
memory onset was we had this think this
scene with their teeth brushing and
Natalie would just come back I mean like
can you just can you tilt angle the
angle the truth and then slightly up but
like slower but more to look like but
more and obviously she wanted but
without being like to make not saying I
want you to look menacing but she would
just get really really specific in from
was like in my entire career I've never
had to do anything this difficult
yes we often got really stropping with
natalie is that you she was she took it
and such good great with such good
grades but ya know you're very specific
notes and also performance notes but
very specific like visual notes I think
that we would also we'd get really
stroppy and pissed off with her and sort
of just sort of be kind of grumpy not
pissed off with her but so it'd be quite
grumpy like grumpy children being you
know told again and again that they had
to do something and not not doing it
right and then we'd go into a trailer
and I remember saying I think this means
she's a genius do you remember we were
like I think it means we're in really
good hands that like the details are so
important and it was it was that was it
was true is that you you kind of got
irritated just but that unit never
didn't you know stop you knowing that
you were in the hands of somebody that
would really is she really is an outer
filmmaker I really believe it and it's
kind of you do you know he just goes to
the ends of the earth for somebody that
you trust and and it was there was
something about her specificity that was
really cool because it was like most
people don't care about how you brush
your teeth but when so when someone does
it means that they are really creating a
very specific universe and that
it's important that you care otherwise
you don't make something good that
attention to detail really pays off with
the build in the film and I cannot
express that enough right now I have to
say goodbye and I don't want to but
really congratulations on the movie and
thank you so much for your time today
relic keep an eye out for it another
huge thanks to Kia for having us here at
the supper suite in Park City like and
share this video before you leave it and
stay tuned for more interviews from the
festival